how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
last night we got possibly the best
episode of marvel's what if so far the
story was fantastic but a lot of us were
wondering how exactly would all of this
tie into the mcu and this episode showed
us how and while the story is amazing
and the next episode is probably going
to be the best episode of the entire
series i definitely want to talk about
how marvel's what if is about to move
into the live action mcu and how we're
going to see some of these characters
pop up in our main mcu timeline probably
in multiverse of madness and of course
with that i'll talk about what exactly
happened in this episode and talk about
some really cool easter eggs that they
showed and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest marvel videos now
this episode is titled what if ultron
won and it's really bad news for
everybody the entire universe in fact
not just our universe but other
universes as well the entire multiverse
is at jeopardy if ultron wins so they
take us through a recap of our main mcu
timeline where ultron did not win but
instead vision was born and with the
help of vision the avengers were able to
defeat ultron therefore saving the world
the universe and the multiverse however
in this what if universe vision is not
born instead ultron takes the body that
he designed for himself he gets nuclear
codes and successfully destroys the
entire planet with nukes however natasha
and clint survived because they were in
a quinjet at the time not on the ground
where the nukes hit so they are
currently kind of the only hope the
episode opens on a scene of natasha and
clint killing ultron's ai drones then
the watcher proceeds to give us the
backstory that i just mentioned however
the age of ultron like the second
avengers movie was titled the watcher
says was only the beginning and then the
mad titan shows up behind him wielding
five infinity stones the sixth one of
course being the mind stone which is in
ultron's head ultron spots the others
realizes that they are the same thing
that is inside of his head immediately
kills thanos and takes them now thanos
is extremely powerful and his skin is
extremely tough but it is no match for
the power of the mind stone so this is
almost actually karma from the other
universe where thanos kills vision by
ripping the mind stone out of his head
in this universe however instead of
killing vision the body that vision had
kills him to get the other infinity
stones from him and from here ultron
realizes that there are other planets
there's not just earth and eventually he
becomes all knowing and he notices the
watcher the watcher realizes this and
says if a hunger like that referring to
ultron was released upon the multiverse
he realizes that the entire multiverse
could be at risk of destruction and this
is how it's going to tie in the mcu and
i have a really big theory on this but
first big thank you to private internet
access for sponsoring this video for
those people in my live streams that
i've been saying that you don't have
access to disney plus yet private
internet access vpn is your solution
through private internet access vpn you
can watch disney plus netflix hulu and
all of the major streaming services from
anywhere in the world despite where you
live what private internet access vpn
does is changes your ip address and
reroutes your internet traffic through
an encrypted tunnel so if you don't have
disney plus where you live you can
change your location to a country like
the usa that does have disney plus and
access disney plus this way while all at
the same time you can safeguard your
online privacy because the vpn software
also blocks ads trackers and malicious
websites and private internet access is
the world's most transparent vpn with
over 30 million downloads and by
clicking the link in the description
down below you can get complete digital
privacy for less than three dollars a
month and two extra months for free
meaning it's only two dollars and eight
cents a month and it's 83 off so ultron
if you noticed was actually standing on
the old avengers tower a nice little
easter egg they threw in there the
avengers were the only thing stopping
ultron from conquering the world so when
he finishes his conquest he finishes it
on the avengers tower and once ultron
gets the infinity stones and realizes
that there is more than earth he begins
to go across the universe doing what he
really thinks is cleansing it this guy
is way worse than thanos he's not trying
to kill half of the population for a
somewhat justifiable cause maybe
depending on how you view thanos but
this guy is simply killing everything so
we go to asgard and he completely
destroys it it looks like asgard is
supposed to be destroyed one way or
another in each universe that it's in
then he goes to the sovereign and we see
the guardians of the galaxy actually
trying to defend it as well and what's
interesting is this does appear to be
peter quill star-lord not t'challa like
we've seen in the past this attack also
is seemingly happening right during the
time of the opening of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2. we then go to sukkar and
we see the grandmaster and dabarikug
trying to kill all of ultron's aize
unfortunately they are unsuccessful and
so car goes down as well he then takes
out ego with ease i might add and then
heads to zandar and if you slow some of
this down you can see some of the people
scrambling some of those people are a
part of the nova corps and yes some of
those people may look like the character
nova but remember all nova corps wear
that helmet now he doesn't have such an
easy time with zandar because captain
marvel shows up and if there was really
anybody who had a chance to stop ultron
it would be captain marvel unfortunately
she is unsuccessful and zandar goes down
so ultron eventually destroys the
universe and he's kind of heartbroken
like the watcher says because he
realizes that his purpose is fulfilled
he is no longer necessary however as the
watcher narrates we realize that ultron
becomes aware of the watcher and the
watcher says that ultron ascends to a
previously unattainable level of
consciousness and this is what allows
ultron to actually become aware of the
watcher and this freaks the watcher out
because he has seen everything in every
universe but he could not see this and
it startles him to the point to where he
actually says what the hell is this and
this is where things start to get very
very big and important not just for the
what if universe that we're watching but
for the entire multiverse of the marvel
cinematic universe and the watcher
actually realizes this and something you
have to take into account is that marvel
studios the people the producers at
marvel studios have said that what if
does connect to the mcu and our question
was always how but this episode helps us
answer that a little bit more and the
answer is the watcher the watcher has
been established in the mcu at this
point as the person who watches over the
multiverse not just one universe but the
multiverse and they have said that this
does take place inside of the mcu that
means the watcher is indeed real in the
main sacred timeline that means that in
the universe that they are currently in
where ultron is threatening the
multiverse he's actually threatening our
sacred timeline as well and we see that
threat become a reality because ultron
actually breaks through his own
universe's barrier and he jumps into the
multiverse and attacks the watcher
ultron just went from despair and having
no purpose anymore to having a brand new
destiny destroying the multiverse and
when he finally finds the watcher the
watcher says you do not have to do this
but ultron says it is my purpose and
from here we get an incredibly epic
fight and i hope we get something very
similar to this in multiverse of madness
because this was insane now the only
hope for the multiverse at this point in
time is natasha and clint and they
search for the files of zola we know
that zola is now an ai and pretty much
the only chance of wiping out ultron and
as they head to siberia ultron and the
watcher go at it in an epic multiversal
fight now as the watcher and ultron
fight we hear a really cool statement
that has a lot of implications towards
the future of the mcu the watcher says
this shouldn't be possible but ultron
then breaks out of the multiverse again
and says oh but anything is possible in
a multiverse and again big implications
towards the actual mcu because the
multiverse is going to exist it
technically already does but it's going
to start to really come into play in
spider-man no way home and doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness in
fact ultron attacking the watcher is
definitely going to contribute to the
madness of what's going to happen in
doctor strange 2. because as we can see
when they fight it's affecting other
universes they arrive to one universe
and the first thing ultron does is
completely wipe it out pretty much
making the universe just a plain desert
and as ultron and the watcher are
fighting ultron says that he lacks the
will to stop him and we get probably one
of the coolest lines in mcu history here
the watcher essentially goes super
saiyan and says you cannot compute the
power of my will they fight again and
they break through several different
multiverses until they land upon one and
ultron becomes galactus huge easter egg
for galactus here the devourer of worlds
we actually see ultron doing what
galactus does eating planets and even
the image that they show of him as he's
going to eat this planet looks just like
him which technically does mean that
galactus is mcu canon now because this
show is mcu canon now what's really
interesting is that ultron slash
galactus actually does devour that
planet in that universe and the watcher
gets sent into another one another one
where captain america has now become
president america steve rogers is being
sworn in as the president of the united
states which we see on a tv in the
background whatever universe this is i
definitely want to see in live action
but then ultron attacks the watcher and
immediately when he smashes him the
universe shatters we're then taken into
a universe where they're at wakanda in
which that shatters as well turning into
a universe where the scroll are but of
course another punch means another
shatter of a universe and here's where
ultron drops the line that is going to
affect the mcu he says the boundaries of
the multiverse are irrelevant to beings
like you and me the watcher then runs he
hides himself in a different universe
but we find out that ultron now has full
control over the ability to jump to
different universes and monitor the
multiverse and this is the ultimate
threat which is why the watcher goes to
our previous friend strange supreme who
has been trapped inside of that crystal
ball this entire time this answers the
question that a lot of people had was he
dead the universe completely ceased to
exist or is he trapped there as it turns
out he is trapped there but the watcher
went there for a specific reason he
needs his help and he asks him for it
this is the first time that the watcher
is going to interfere because the
multiverse is at jeopardy and that's
going to lead into the final episode
where the watcher kind of puts together
a team that is kind of like an avengers
but a galaxy multiversal avengers and
this is most likely why the illuminati
is going to be formed in our mcu it's
rumored that the illuminati and
multiverse of madness are going to be
revealed and they're going to be a
multiversal illuminati tasked with
protecting the multiverse along with the
watcher because remember the watcher is
not supposed to interfere however he
kind of had to in this situation but
hopefully after this it leads to the
event and the formation of the
illuminati and they will be the
protectors of the multiverse and since
we're getting strange supreme i would
like to think that somehow he is
actually going to affect doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness perhaps
strange supreme and the watcher have to
warn our doctor strange in our main
universe the sacred timeline about what
is happening again after no way home in
multiverse of madness it seems like the
multiverse is going to become a lot more
than just chaos a lot more than just
madness it looks like it's all going to
come crashing down and i think after
next episode the last episode of
marvel's what if of this season we're
going to have a lot better of an idea of
what to expect so last chance to drop
all your theories about what is going to
happen after the final episode of
marvel's what if right now drop them all
in the comments down below and let me
know what you thought of this episode
rate it from 1 to 10. 10 being the best
don't forget to subscribe for more
marvel content don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof